You have to slow down and slowing down
means you have to reflect and it means
that you have to listen and listen and
listen some more.
When you start to truly listen,
what happens is that you begin to again,
self reflect and that isn't necessarily
the most comfortable thing.
Over the last 25 years in working in
professional service firms over and over
again,
I would find myself talking with
conversing with individuals who in many
respects never wanted to slow down
incredibly smart,
a little bit defensive when you gave
them feedback,
um,
felt in many respects that they were
really good at everything that they did,
um,
without ever asking actually some tough
questions about whether they really were
competent or not in things like
management,
who after a while seem to spend more
time managing their image than actually
worrying about are,
am I really improving or am I trying new
things?
And it seemed like that they were
becoming more and more frightened.
I'm about about some very,
very basic things while their lives seem
to be working and they seem to be
progressing and they seem to be
achieving and accomplishing.
If for some reason you tell them that
they're falling down in a particular
area,
what happens is they begin to see
themselves as an absolute failure as
opposed to saying,
well,
you know,
I'm overwhelmed.
I have a lot of things that I need to
balance.
Anything that gets in the way of them
not accomplishing at the end of the day
starts to feel like a distraction.
Often relationships begin to suffer with
these individuals.
They find themselves rather than
listening with their children,
they find themselves asking for
accountability.
They find themselves a giving directions
and offering advice.
They find themselves asking questions
like,
what did you do today?
Have you done your homework?
Have you applied for college?
I mean,
you're seven years old.
Why aren't you applying for college?
How was your room dirty?
And so they're still in that role of
accomplish.
Check things off.
When you start having those kinds of
feelings of,
you know what?
I may be inadequate and these other
dimensions.
What you do is you find yourself going
faster and faster.